two decades of civil war no government a
haven for international piracy a
militant uprising and a million refugees
Somalia has long been the international
model of a failed state a new president
was elected a year ago and his
government's influence is starting to
take root he's trying to move this
impoverished nation from an emergency to
a recovery phase but Somalia's
challenges like its social structure a
complex and varied that's where the
European Union through its comprehensive
approach to the Horn of Africa wants to
play a role with three missions
political support and more than a
billion euros in assistance the EU is
trying to help get Somalia back on the
road to recovery security is the biggest
challenge so building up the army is a
high priority it's a big task that
Europe's tackling through its military
training mission EU TM Somalia the
presence of the UTM Somalia in Mogadishu
is most certainly an accelerator as far
as the European Union is concerned
establishing a a future foothold an
expanding future foothold in Mogadishu
and in throughout Somalia that we will
be able to provide situational awareness
provide logistical support force
protection support to ensure that all of
the requirements for a secure deployment
of the full spectrum of EU actors both
in Mogadishu and Somalia is in place
to helped Somalia defend itself UTM has
moved into the Jazeera camp in Mogadishu
for the last three years the mission has
been training some 3,000 Somali soldiers
and officers remotely in Uganda trainees
will now be lodged here in some of the
camp's 130 buildings as part of the
comprehensive European approach to State
Building
EU TM staff also advised the Defense
Ministry and the EU funds the African
peacekeeping force here work at Jazeera
goes on bolstering the camp's perimeter
with sandbags and watchtowers the chief
security threat in Somalia comes from
al-shabaab a hardline Islamist group
linked to al-qaeda fighters routinely
launch attacks in Mogadishu to show that
they can strike anywhere anytime
much of the European Union's political
capital goes into supporting this man
president Hassan Sheikh Mohammed this
flight offshore to meet EU commanders
came the day after an Al Shabab attempt
on his life the president has been in
office a year and he's working to
project his influence throughout Somalia
the New Deal conference in Brussels in
September which secured new funds and
international support is said to help
his government restore stability the
counter-piracy operation EU naval force
Atalanta is currently run from the dutch
ship johan Davitt it's a huge floating
dock capable of launching fast boats to
chase down pirate skiffs the force
watches over one of the world's major
shipping areas in fact we have four
tasks first of all we protect World Food
Program ships we deter and suppress
piracy we protect vulnerable shipping
and we contribute to the monitoring of
fishing activities of the coast of
Somalia
the biggest challenge is the amount of
water because the size of the area we
patrolling over here is the size of
Europe the EU nav for operation
commander has no doubts about the value
of the operation Europe relies on the
trade that goes through the
bab-el-mandeb straits 5,000 ships a
month pass through there I should think
80% of that on their way north through
there and up to Suez is going to conduct
trade with Europe if we don't have
confidence in that route then all of a
sudden one of our key interests is
affected
international efforts at see the robust
patrolling by warships combined with the
work of private security firms on cargo
vessels have helped to thwart the
pirates but much work remains to be done
on land to provide jobless Somalis with
other opportunities what we know is that
we have brought piracy down by 90
percent that's a great statistic but
actually things haven't changed ashore
and networks are still in place and if
we take the pressure off there's
absolutely no reason why piracy won't
reimburse as a difficult issue for us so
we've got to stay here until the seas
are controlled given Somalia's security
challenges ships like the johan davit
are also being used as floating
classrooms to help tackle the problems
of piracy closer to the shore in the
safety of these vessels the EU cap nest
or mission is helping to build up the
coastguard
staff train police and customs officers
in an effort to contain the problem
before any would-be pirates make it out
to international waters
in the Somali Basin EU naval force
personnel head out to round up suspects
and question boat owners they build up a
database of information that will help
identify repeat offenders and pinpoint
the source of the piracy problem in an
exercise on deck
Somalia's top justice officials are
taught about European evidence gathering
techniques this is knowledge they can
use to collect handle and process
materials found at a potential crime
scene its expertise they can use when
pirates face them in court
it's just one part of EU cap Nestor's
work but it's all part of shifting the
focus from piracy at sea back to the
land were extremes of poverty climate
and ideology created the problem in the
first place our success with piracy and
the changes in Somalia with the federal
Somali government mean that there's
space and time now to look at this
problem ashore the roots of the piracy
problem lie assures the symptoms lion
see so we need to really get to the
heart of this disease and at the heart
of this disease lie problems of
unemployment particularly among young
men many jobs were lost in the fishing
sector due to piracy and illegal fishing
by foreigners one of the issues is how
do we deal with this boys can we provide
an alternative way of life so that they
will not attempt to venture again to
adventure again into the sea European
Union Hospital
investment a lot of money on that
direction and that issue is going
underway now and the EU funds the you
expertise all will be facilitating to
move Somalia to push some attitudes that
direction
through its civilian and military
operations development assistance and
political support the European Union is
trying to help get Somalis back to work
by providing security and investment
it's the hope of a better life that
might starve al-shabaab of recruits and
keep young men off the high seas